ME TOO MOVEMENT.
THIS IS "SPECIAL REPORT" ."
GOOD EVENING.
WELCOME TO WASHINGTON.
I'M SHANNON BREAM IN FOR
BRET BAIER.
WOULD BEGIN WITH A HYPOTHETICAL
THAT IS CAUSING SOME VERY REAL
CONCERN ABOUT THE PRESIDENT, THE
SPECIAL COUNSEL, AND THE
CONSTITUTION.
PRESIDENT TRUMP SAYS HE HAS THE
RIGHT TO PARDON HIMSELF SHOULD
THE RUSSIA CUSHION PROBE MAKE IT
NECESSARY BUT HE SAYS THERE WILL
BE NO NEED SINCE THERE IS -- IT
IS UNCONSTITUTIONAL AND HE IS
INNOCENT.
GOOD EVENING, JOHN ROBERTS.
>> A WEEK FROM TODAY,
PRESIDENT TRUMP US HAD TO SIT
DOWN FOR A HISTORIC SUMMIT WITH
THE LEADER OF NORTH KOREA, BUT
EVEN AS HE PREPARES FOR THAT
MEETING, PRESIDENT STILL VERY
MUCH HAS THE RUSSIA
INVESTIGATION ON HIS MIND.
PRESIDENT TRUMP BEGAN HIS 500TH
DAY IN OFFICE BY IGNITING A
FIRESTORM OF LEGAL AND POLITICAL
DEBATE.
DIVING BACK INTO THE RUSSIA
INVESTIGATION.
ANY BREAKFAST WHEAT, INSISTING,
AS HAS BEEN STATED BY NUMEROUS
LEGAL SCHOLARS, I HAVE THE
ABSOLUTE RIGHT TO PARDON MYSELF
BUT WHY WOULD I DO THAT WHEN I
HAVE DONE NOTHING WRONG?
IN A CONFERENCE CALL WITH
SUPPORTERS, PRESIDENT TRUMP
DOUBLE DOWN ON A MORNING TWEET
THAT THE MUELLER PROBE IS
TOTALLY UNCONSTITUTIONAL.
>> President Trump: IT'S NOT
EVEN CONSTITUTIONAL.
IN MY OPINION.
>> THE PARDON ISSUE SURFACED IN
THE LETTER PRESIDENT TRUMP'S
OUTSIDE COUNSEL WROTE TO ROBERT
MUELLER IN JANUARY, THE LETTER
OBTAINED BY FOX NEWS LAID OUT
MYRIAD REASONS WHY MUELLER HAS
NO LEGAL STANDING TO ASK FOR AN
INTERVIEW WITH THE PRESIDENT.
ATTORNEYS JOHN DOWD AND JAY
SEKULOW ARGUE THE PRESIDENT
COULD COME IF YOU WISH,
TERMINATE THE INQUIRY OR EVEN
EXERCISE HIS POWER TO PARDON.
DEMOCRATS RUSHED TO SAY NO, HE
COULDN'T.
>> IT'S NOT THE RULE OF TRUMP.
IT IS THE RULE OF LAW WE LIVE
UNDER IN THE UNITED STATES OF
AMERICA.
EVEN IN 1974, RICHARD NIXON'S
JUSTICE DEPARTMENT MADE IT QUITE
CLEAR THAT NIXON COULD NOT
PARDON HIMSELF.
THE SAME THING IS TRUE HERE.
>> PRESIDENT TRUMP'S CURRENT
OUTSIDE COUNSEL, RUDY JULIANA,
SAYS THE PRESIDENT LIKELY DOES
HAVE THE POWER PARTED
HIMSELF THOUGH TO DO SO WOULD BE
POLITICAL SUICIDE.
>> THE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES PARDONING HIMSELF
WOULD BE UNTHINKABLE AND WOULD
LEAD TO PROBABLY IMMEDIATE
IMPEACHMENT.
>> PRESS SECRETARY SARAH SANDERS
ADDED THERE IS NO REASON FOR A
PARDON.
>> THE PRESIDENT HASN'T DONE
ANYTHING AND TRICKLE WRONG AND
WOULD NEED ONE.
>> THE LETTER REIGNITED ANOTHER
CONTROVERSY.
WHAT ROLE DID THE PRESIDENT PLAY
IN DRAFTING THE INITIAL
STATEMENT FROM DONALD TRUMP JR.
IN RESPONSE THAT 2016 MEETING
WITH THE RUSSIAN ATTORNEY.
A FOUR DAYS AFTER THE STATEMENT,
OUTSIDE COUNSEL JAY SEKULOW SAID
THE PRESIDENT WAS NOT INVOLVED.
>> THAT WAS WRITTEN BY
DONALD TRUMP JR. AND IMS WERE
WITHIN CONSULTATION WITH HIS
LAWYER.
>> THE PRESS SECRETARY LATER
SAID HE WAS INVOLVED BUT ONLY
MARGINALLY.
>> HE DIDN'T DICTATE.
HE WEIGHED IN, OFFERED
SUGGESTION LIKE ANY FATHER WOULD
DO.
>> THE JANUARY LETTER WRITTEN BY
JAY SEKULOW CONTRADICTS BOTH OF
THOSE STATEMENTS.
IT INFORMS MUELLER YOU HAVE
RECEIVED ALL OF THE NOTES,
COMMUNICATIONS, AND TESTIMONY
INDICATING THAT THE PRESIDENT
DICTATED A SHORT BUT ACCURATE
RESPONSE TO "THE NEW YORK TIMES"
ARTICLE ON BEHALF OF HIS SON,
DONALD TRUMP JR.
GIULIANI BELIEVES PSYCHE       S
GIULIANI BELIEVES PSYCHE       K
GIULIANI BELIEVES PSYCHE       L
GIULIANI BELIEVES PSYCHE       W
MISSPOKE.
>> I THINK HE WAS WRONG.
>> THE PRESIDENT'S ATTORNEYS
ARGUED THAT THE STATEMENT WAS A
PRIVATE MATTER BETWEEN THE
PRESIDENT AND
"THE NEW YORK TIMES."
A PRIVATE MATTER THAT ROBERT
MUELLER HAS NO BUSINESS STICKING
HIS NOSE INTO.
GIULIANI ADDED YESTERDAY THAT HE